the new Tesla PI phone is a work of art
hold on it's a technological
breakthrough with the Giants of the
smartphone industry becoming
increasingly complacent with the yearly
minimal upgrades of their devices this
is Elon musk's chance to cause a major
shake-up in the smartphone industry with
the announcement of the Tesla Model Pi
gripes with apple Elon Musk is an iPhone
user and has openly criticized them this
is what he said people are used to the
phone being better every year I'm an
iPhone user but I think some of the
recent software updates have not been
great certainly feeding into that point
it like broke my email system which is
quite fundamental other disadvantages of
the iPhone which have been noted are the
inability to increase the built-in
storage or difficulty in tethering the
device to a Windows PC or laptop besides
these disadvantages the Apple iPhone is
a terrific smartphone and is a good
choice for anyone but many more
smartphones can do the same functions if
you have the option to have something
way better like the Tesla PI phone you
should want 100 go for it let's get into
the nitty-gritty of the Tesla python
exterior and design Tesla has brought
the same design philosophy that has
punctuated its other successful products
its cars combine great looks with
performance and are among the best
looking electric vehicles on the market
now the PI phone shares the same
sleekness and bold attractive colors you
will appreciate the sleekness when you
hold or behold it the Innovations of the
exterior of the Python range from little
tricks such as changing color when you
turn it into the sunlight to Giant leaps
such as housing a solar panel at the
back you heard that right a solar panel
built in more on that later the Tesla PI
phone reportedly comes with a 6.9 inch
Super AMOLED full touchscreen display
with an 8K resolution allowing you to
see in high quality without lagging the
ability to change color in the sunlight
is due to a photochromic coating on the
surface of the phone on the front you'll
find a 108 megapixel camera but here's
the catch unlike other phones the the
camera is completely placed underneath
the screen and you will only notice its
presence when you do a video call or
take a selfie this makes the Tesla PI
phone largely free of notches and holes
that plague other phone makers the front
camera isn't the only thing being kept
under the screen because there is also a
fingerprint scanner under the screen
there are a total of four camera lenses
at the back a 200 megapixel primary lens
a 24 megapixel Ultra wide lens a 16
megapixel white sensor and a 5 megapixel
depth sensor with the ability to space
zoom up to 200 times these lenses would
elevate your photography experience to
another level either you're out with
family on the beach on a Sunday
afternoon or you're stargazing with your
loved one at night this is a camera
that's built for any and all occasions
unlike in most phones the Tesla camera
lenses are placed in the uppermost
Center instead of the corner and this
unique orientation is more than
Aesthetics it allows for a larger
battery pack and thus longer life
powered by the Sun as a servant
supporter of being green Elon Musk would
stop at nothing to advance beyond the
use of charging cables by implementing
solar panels into the Tesla PI phone in
addition he is always trying to improve
and create new solar and Battery
Technology in 2016 he acquired SolarCity
a clean energy business for 2.6 billion
dollars and integrated the business into
Tesla energy which is a subsidiary of
Tesla Tesla energy strives to offer
solar services to homes including the
installation of solar batteries with
access to these resources it makes sense
that Elon Musk would integrate the use
of this solar technology into a phone
that requires no charger turning the
phone upside down is enough to start
recharging batteries when you run out of
energy that is provided it's sunny
outside of course with musk being a
battery Enthusiast there is no doubt
that the battery is going to be packing
heavy duty the maximum milliamp is going
to be 7 000 and light use is sufficient
to carry you throughout the day without
needing to recharge you'll be able to
stream your favorite Netflix show browse
the internet or play the latest Call of
Duty mobile without fear of the battery
running out quickly car control Tesla
already has an Android and iPhone app
that allows users to control their Tesla
cars with just their mobile devices the
app does the basic things such as
allowing users to lock or unlock their
automobiles start or stop the engine a
media controller and locate the vehicle
however the Tesla python would come with
the car control feature already built
into it and users will not require to
download an application to use it the
smartphone would be equipped with
Cutting Edge technology to match Tesla's
automobiles which means you can use your
phone hands-free while driving summon
the vehicle when you're away and even
drive the car from the python extra
functions may be provided in the PI
phone for Tesla car owners this includes
AI chauffeur and Robo taxi which has
been teased by Elon Musk in past
interviews satellite connectivity the
Tesla pay phone is permanently connected
to the satellite meaning you'll be
connected to the internet 24 7. space
SpaceX started launching starlink
satellites in 2019 and as of September
2022 starlink consists of over 3 000
mass-produced more satellites in low
earth orbit the introduction of
satellite connectivity to the Tesla
python is a game changer as the internet
and network offered by satellite are
massively Superior to that offered by
cellular networks the satellite internet
is rapid and efficient with download
speeds reaching up to 200 megabytes per
second it will also let you send SMS
even when you don't have signal the
numerous hurdles of cellular internet
will also be a thing of the past and
these hurdles include poor connectivity
when hiking in the rainforests of Costa
Rica a ski trip in the Rocky Mountains
or even the avoidable lagging of
WhatsApp video calls with the Tesla
python a sailor in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean will have an excellent
uninterrupted video call with his
business partner in a remote settlement
in Africa starlink will soon extend its
services to Mars so whether you're on
Earth or Mars you can be a should of a
rapid internet connection mind phone
connection musk owns another firm called
neuralink and neurolink is the future of
technology the very words of Elon Musk
are smartphones are yesterday's
technology neuralink is the present the
company's aim is the creation of a
smooth interface between computers and
the human brain allowing people to
control computers just by thinking about
them the neuralink app is still in
production and integration into the
Tesla python might come later down the
line even though it seems far-fetched a
sneak peek into the neuralink research
shows a monkey playing mind Pawn with
nothing but its mind neuralink must
still clear several moral and legal
obstacles before it achieves its
objective of merging man with machine
neuralink will make communication easier
for people struggling with language
hurdles people with mental illnesses as
well as speech impaired people they just
need to think about anything and the
Tesla python will understand it with a
regular smartphone if you want to play a
song on YouTube you would have to switch
application to YouTube search for the
song and press play but with the neural
link integrated into the Tesla python
all you have to do is think about the
song and boom it plays convenient right
crypto mining Elon Musk is a fan of
cryptocurrency and as an investor and
Enthusiast of Dogecoin it isn't
surprised that Elon Musk would try to
incorporate cryptocurrency functionality
into the Tesla PI phone thanks to the
powerful chip in the Tesla PI phone you
can mine crypto the crypto in question
is the Mars coin one that musk will
introduce for the eventual Mars settlers
so that they have their own currency now
if you're lucky enough to be the owner
of a PI phone as well as a citizen of
Mars you will have a powerful device
used to Crunch out cryptos you can store
the coins or make transactions with it
making your python act as your ATM card
as well as a bank seeing that the Tesla
python will also be available for Earth
citizens too business transactions can
be done from Earth to Mars now that's
what I call an Interstellar transaction
storage and capacity if you're concerned
about the storage of the Tesla python
we've not forgotten about that the
storage capacity of a smartphone is what
guides many users on what to purchase
and the Tesla PI phone does not
disappoint an Apple iPhone can hold up
to 512 gigabytes of data and that is
already quite a lot but the Tesla PI
phone is rumored to Dazzle the market
with a whopping two terabytes along with
unlimited cloud storage this is even
more than my personal computer and many
of your personal computers the ram is
also necessary for Speed and fast
processing a lot of the Tesla Python's
contemporaries clock out at 4 gigabytes
of RAM but the python boasts 8 gigabytes
of RAM pricing and affordability the
Tesla PI phone is rumored to cost around
twelve hundred dollars in the United
States and that's not surprising based
on all the Staggering features mentioned
above Tesla is no stranger to expensive
products but what is guaranteed is that
you will get absolute value for dollars
spent the announcement of the Tesla
Payphone is going to cause a much needed
shakeup in the smartphone industry with
the innovative features in the Tesla
python threatening to make Apple and
Samsung obsolete in the next 10 years
they have no choice but to sit up
because I currently doubt anyone would
be able to use a Samsung phone on Mars
the release would also Aid in broadening
the ecosystem of Tesla as it would allow
Tesla car owners to purchase the Python
and the PI phone owners to purchase
Tesla cars well hey when life gives you
lemons buy a Tesla if you enjoyed this
video check out our other awesome videos
on the channel thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time